واستمع ، تذكر أن الوزير مينوشين
كان هنا العام الماضي في زيارة للديوان الملكي
، لم يحضر هذا الحدث ، لكنني
أعتقد في نهاية اليوم أن الولايات
المتحدة تحاول إظهار التضامن
مع المملكة وولي العهد
وهم  يحاولون أيضًا الإشارة إلى أنهم
يؤمنون بالتقدم المستقبلي لتلك
الإصلاحات التي يدفعها ، ولذا فأنا
متفائل بشأن تلك الإصلاحات.
حدث كما فعل ولي العهد ،
لكن أحد الأشياء التي سأكون
حذرا للغاية منها كأميركي أعتقد
أننا نتراجع وننظر إلى
السياق التاريخي عبر التاريخ ، أعتقد أنه
حكم سيء للغاية خاصة كرجل
أعمال أمريكي لإدخال
نفسي  في السياسة الداخلية
للدول الأخرى ، كما أنه من السيء جدًا
أن تكون متقدسًا حيال ذلك
لأنك تعلم أن كل أمة قد
شهدت صعودًا وهبوطًا ومصائبها في
تاريخها  هناك أشياء
للأسف في الولايات المتحدة
نأسف عليها جميعًا من
منظور تاريخي وإدراك متأخر ، لذا فأنا مرة أخرى
لا أعتذر عن ذلك ، فأنا لا أقول
أنه كان أي شيء آخر غير
مأساة وأنا أستنكر بوضوح
واستنكر ما حدث ولكني  أنا أقول فقط
إنه يتعين علينا التراجع
والنظر إليه في سياق ما نحن فيه
اليوم ونصلي من أجل التقدم ونختار
الصلاة من أجل السلام والازدهار